here in wuhan
on the 8th of december 2019 the first
patient was registered with the symptoms
of an unknown disease according to local
government records
later we would learn to call it covid19
many of the initial cases were clustered
around this seafood market
long since closed but only recently
decorated
this hospital is close to the seafood
market and this is where as december
wore on
people came with an atypical pneumonia
an atypical pneumonia that quickly
became
a public health emergency public health
emergency that became a pandemic
those early reports alerted professor
tuong yin qing
regional commander for taiwan's
infectious disease prevention and
treatment network
he flew to wuhan in january and met
chinese officials
i think yeah something wrong
the first thing maybe they are not well
prepared
the second one may be that they are too
busy one
or something they want to hide
professor chuang was particularly
skeptical of the official chinese
narrative
that the new disease could not be
transmitted from human to human
they try to to deny
the possibility of human to human
transmission and then
the higher official administration
limited human to human transmission
cannot be excluded
that means that that is human to human
transmission disease
for no doubt professor trung made the
call well before china and the who
finally announced human transmission he
warned the taiwanese government which
became the first to impose strict border
controls and quarantines
just seven people have died from kovid
there during the whole pandemic
and he tried to warn the world a week
later
wuhan went into lockdown the first of
the pandemic
and at the time a radical unproven
measure
it was chaotic and scary but it did not
stop sung
working
has long since returned to normal life
but what started here has killed more
than one and a half
million people in just one year and it
continues to rage around the world
there is still so much we just do not
know tom cheshire sky news wuhan